Stephen Flynn the New Westminster leader
for the SMP is with us hi hello good
morning thanks for coming in much
appreciated can I ask you about that to
start with yes to other things do you
know um what it says about about how
much money you have managed to have in
addition earned in addition to or been
donated in addition to your salary I'm a
particularly boring MP who just gets on
with their job of representing their
constituents so I'd expect it to see
absolutely nothing as is the case for
most of my colleagues to be honest I
think it's just I think it's about six
thousand three thousand there you go
three thousand two hundred pounds
um in totals so very different to what
some of the others can you clarify those
figures for us yeah of course when I was
first elected to Parliament I was also a
sitting counselor in Aberdeen's that was
just the overlap between me and in my
period on the local Authority and of
course joining Parliament it wasn't a
second job prose it was just an overlap
what do you make of the amount of money
that some MPS can earn as a second job
we've heard from Kia stama he says that
he doesn't think there should only be
very
um tiny circumstances when people can
have a second job and I'm not sure
whether that includes Dave what David
Lam is earning or not we've not really
been able to we've asked anybody's not
to answer the question what do you think
I I don't think the the MPS on the face
of it should have second jobs I think
they should be focused on their
constituents and making sure that
they're represented not just in
Parliament but in the constituency as
well now there is obviously
circumstances where that may well not
apply in its entirety I know for
instance one of my colleagues who is an
eminent cancer so Sergeant volunteer
some of their time in order to to
provide that service to people a
justifiable service I think that is
important I know there's a liberal
Member of Parliament who does that as
well but broadly speaking and seeing the
likes of Theresa May Boris Johnson
another senior figures raking millions
of pounds will stick in the car of so
many people right across Who Can't Be At
This Moment In Time are struggling to
put two fence together but doesn't um
having MPS have a different career as
well make for better politicians rather
than just career politicians who don't
know what the real world's like but
politicians are there to legislate to
make laws and to ensure that all of our
lives are are better they're not there
to be celebrities they're not there to
feather their own nest and they're
certainly not there to rake in millions
of pounds through and course entirely
because of the position that they have
in Westminster Theresa May is not
getting invited to these things because
she's a particularly good or engaging
speaker she's getting invited because
she used to hold the Office of Prime
Minister and I think we need to have a
realistic discussion about whether
that's appropriate or not I don't think
it's appropriate and I think
overwhelming majority of the people
don't think congratulations on the new
job why did you feel that you wanted to
outstand Blackford I think it's
important this discussion to reflect
upon the fact that where we are as
Scottish national party MPS at this
moment in time is in a video position
we've seen that at the supreme court
judgment of course that Scotland's
democracy does not matter within the UK
I want us to be assertive within the
House of Commons I want to put democracy
first and I want to make sure that the
voice of the people of Scotland has
heard in the House of Commons are right
across this country so why did you ask
him I didn't oustian Ian no of course
they still wanted the job and he wanted
it too so how would you describe it well
Ian of course stood down with his own
accord he said that uh himself and of
course we had a leadership election
myself and Alison still let's put
ourselves forward and I was delighted
that my colleagues put their their faith
in me to lead them in the House of
Commons and hopefully lead us to uh to
Independence which is an incredibly
exciting thing the only reason I asked
you that and you know this is your
opportunity to clarify the situation Joe
Pike one of my colleagues
um esteemed colleague said that um you
were the parliamentarian behind the
queue and its main beneficiary but you
never confronted Mr Blackford directly
is that not fair I did see Joe's piece
uh online I don't think Joe's piece
necessarily reflects the entirety of
reality I'm afraid to say and of course
well I don't think what Joe said was it
was accurate uh well he said to me that
a list was was put forward a list I've
never seen a list in any way shape or
form he also made a number of other
surgeons uh comments from her colleagues
as well which did did I did find a
little bit questionable I have to say
but um that this is the the nature of
the world that we live in uh sadly okay
so how do you feel about this
suggestions that you're at the heart of
a Ladish group of beer swilling
separatist MPS
it sounds like a pretty exciting life
but it's not the one that I lead uh I'm
afraid to say I've seen a number of
suggestions about myself and my
character and they just don't tie into
reality at all I have to say I've
personally been a little bit upset by
them I there's been a suggestion that
I'm leader of a vindaloo Curry I think
it was one of the right wing places yeah
yeah you're all meeting tomorrow I'm not
even a member of any clubs in
Westminster so I'm a little bit
surprised this I do of course like many
other people up and then they can't
really play five besides occasionally on
a Tuesday night which for me is a big
thing I spent 18 years as a with a club
no no I spent 18 years as a disabled man
so the opportunity to go and play
football on a Tuesday night is something
which I greatly appreciate I do it about
once a month for a group of other
people's staff included I don't think
there's anything wrong with people
wanting to play five sides but they're
surgeons that I like Curry that I drink
but I don't even like Curry it's this
isn't going to win me votes particularly
in Scotland I don't even like it and I'm
getting told I'm the leader of a
vindaloo Club it's uh it's all a little
bit of something okay let's just to talk
about Patrick Grady and then we'll move
on
um Patrick Grady was trying to have
acted in appropriately it was a male SNP
member but you restored the whip to it
so Patrick's decision his decision at an
SMP social event to touch a member of
staff on the head's neck and shoulder
was completely out of order it was wrong
and it should never have happened the
House of Commons agreed with that which
is why they put in place a two-day
suspension the SMP grip at that time
back in June or July I could meet with
that as well and put in a suspension for
Patrick and of course the party our
national secretary referred Patrick to
the memory conduct committee Patrick was
given a six-month suspension from the
party that suspension from the party
elapsed and of course if you are a
member of the Scottish national party
you're entitled to Citizen SMP member at
Westminster or indeed anywhere else has
he learned his lesson I would hope so um
certainly from the report which which I
read which was the expert panel report
which put forward its recommendations in
relation to Patrick's suspension they
said that he had they said he'd gone
through training from my brief
discussions with Patrick Lindell he's
filmed regret and Robert Morrison
certainly all I can say is I'm
incredibly sorry that the complainant
has had to go through this and I hope
that we don't have our key investment
touched inappropriately are they content
with what the outcome is now judging by
what I've seen in the media I don't
think that the complainant is Happy of
course the fact that they were touched
on the head shoulder and neck shouldn't
have happened it would be extremely
difficult thing to happen to anyone
reach the ball at a staff member from
someone uh above them with a position of
privilege Patrick recognizes that was
wrong the party has gone through its
disciplinary process that's six months
suspension has concluded and of course
as I said once that six months
suspension is included okay concluded
I've I've got to be in a position where
he's a member of the SMP group no I
think in your new role you've already
written to secure starmer asking to team
up with your party to defeat these new
legislative plans for minimum service
levels during strikes does that mean
that you're in favor of strikes that
means I'm in favor of workers having the
right as a last resort to withdraw their
labor in order to protect their own
interests to to get better pay and of
course when we're having this discussion
let's not forget the real wages at this
moment in time or somewhere akin to what
they were in 2006 the cost of living
crisis is real as deep in it as having
huge consequences we are in a ridiculous
situation in Scotland where our
overwhelming majority of uh politicians
in Scotland's Parliament would be clear
that workers right should be protected
but under the Devolution settlement it's
for the UK Tories to decide what happens
what we are saying to Kirsten is let's
work together to block this legislation
let's put workers rights first and if he
doesn't want to work together to block
it at least make that commitment that
should he ever become Prime Minister and
Scotland still remain part of the United
Kingdom that he'll devolve employment
law to Scotland something which a labor
party has blocked on numerous occasions
did you see the Harry interview last
night I didn't know do you have a view
in terms of everything that's happened
with with Harry
um I do I think everyone has a view this
at this moment
um I find some of the comments I've not
seen other things that appears a new
story is breaking almost every hour I
found some of his comments quite
disturbing particularly in relation to
the deaths which he accounts in the
manner in which he talks about it in his
time in the armed forces yeah I think
it's quite there's just a number I'm
honest um but similarly I Have A Little
Bit of Sympathy for him and the fact
that his wife Meghan Markle has been
attacked severely by the right-wing
British press for three reasons three
reasons as far as I can see it she's
female she's black and she's successful
and they don't like it so I can
understand why he would be frustrated
and want to be defensive of his of his
partner as well okay first time we've
chatted hopefully first of many it's
good to see you